well the joe biden vax mandate went down
to absolute flaming defeat at the
supreme court level six to three six
justices finding it was a complete
relegation of congressional authority to
nothingness to allow osha
to do whatever it wanted to do with
regard to vaccine mandates that
essentially they were exceeding the
scope of their authority in
unconstitutional fashion
and because that vax mandate went down
you're now starting to see major
companies who are
getting rid of their own vaccine
mandates
now i do think
that there is a right and wrong here
right we here at the daily wire day one
we said that we would not be imposing a
vast mandate on our people why because
we actually followed the data and what
we saw is that people who wanted to get
vast were able to get facts and if you
were vast you are now effectively safe
as you could be from the virus because
the virus is now endemic
and so we said if you don't want to get
facts that is on you and by the way if
you have natural immunity the data are
now showing the natural immunity is more
durable than vax immunity by a pretty
significant margin so we're not going to
force you to get backs particularly if
you already have natural immunity
there are other companies that are out
there who shall remain nameless who have
been pushing the vax mandate since
november
october
and who continue to push it even after
the federal government has gone to fl
down to flaming defeat here one of those
companies however that is not doing that
is starbucks so yesterday starbucks
announced that they would stop requiring
its u.s employees to be vaccinated
against cover 19 or submit to regular
testing
starbucks said
that they would they would quit it they
weren't going to do this anymore and the
reason they're not going to do this
anymore of course is because they're
afraid of losing employees they're
afraid of losing workers so they've
decided to suspend their own worker vacs
and test mandate according to the new
york times quote the supreme court's
ruling last week shutting down the biden
administration's effort to enlist large
employers in its vaccination campaign
experts said would trigger a new wave of
uncertainty about how companies keep
workers safe from cover 19. the answer
is they don't because no one keeps
anybody safe from coven 19 all you can
do is keep yourself safe from covet 19
by getting a vaccination if you so
choose that's it now we're done
starbucks with 9 000 us coffee shops and
200 000 workers has become one of the
first major retailers to backtrack on
vax plan since the ruling
starbucks told its employees in a memo
on tuesday they would no longer be
required to be fully vaccinated or
submit to weekly coronavirus testing
just two weeks earlier the company had
detailed the requirement and set a
deadline of february 9th
the supreme court decision did not
prohibit companies from keeping their
vaccine rules in place many will
continue rolling out stringent covet 19
safety protocols starbucks's move
highlights how the court's ruling has
put the responsibility for determining
vac's rules on employers companies face
a patchwork of federal state and local
laws which range from vaccine mandates
that are stricter than the feds to laws
blocking companies from requiring
workers to wear masks
retailers and their advocates have been
the most vocal critics of the federal
government's vaccine rules saying it
would have exacerbated their struggle to
hire or hold on to workers when millions
of unemployed americans remain on the
sidelines in the job market
some labor lawyers say they think other
companies will follow starbucks and
relaxing or undoing their company
mandates which of course is exactly what
they should do
meanwhile carhartt has stuck with its
coven 19 vaccine mandate and there is
evident backlash
according to joseph davila reporting for
the wall street journal one week after
apparel company carhart inc declared it
was keeping its cover 19 vaccine mandate
in place the company defended its plans
despite growing pushback from customers
and on social media
some people said they would stop buying
carhartt products and said the company
shouldn't be forcing its employees to
choose between getting vaccinated and
keeping their job
other customers welcomed the company's
mandate and thanked carhartt for keeping
their employees safe the workwear
apparel maker based in dearborn michigan
said it decided to keep its own vax
mandate to ensure workplace safety
last week's ruling from the supreme
court striking down the biden
administration's vaccine mandate didn't
affect the company's own mandate
the spokeswoman said carhartt fully
understands and respects the varying
opinions on this topic we're aware some
of our associates do not support this
policy however we stand behind our
decisions because we believe vaccines
are necessary to protect our workforce
and so carhart is really feeling the
heat they're feeling particularly
because again the vast majority of
people who shop at carhartt are probably
red state voters
carhartt is known for making blue collar
work wear in recent years its heavy
jackets and hats have become a favorite
among actors and models as well
prior to the announcement the company
was mentioned on average about 550 times
a day on twitter
after the letter from the leadership
began circulating on social media that
number went up to 25 000 on wednesday
more than 4 000 tweets used the hashtag
boycott carhart and other related terms
on wednesday
and listen i think that this is a good
thing all of these companies get to
decide for themselves and then feel the
blowback
general electric changed its vax
requirements in december after a federal
court blocked the biden administration's
vaccine requirements for federal
contractors the company suspended its
remaining facts or test mandate
following the supreme court ruling but
citigroup is keeping it
united airlines has defended its own vax
requirements announced in august
they said recently that the mandate has
likely saved the lives of about eight to
ten employees
so what like based on based on what
the airline had been reporting about one
coveted 19 death week among staffers
prior to the mandate's implementation
so we'll see how many companies decide
to allow their workers freedom and how
many companies decide to uh to continue
along this path and then we'll get to
respond as we as we see fit obviously
i know what you're thinking it's time to
binge some more ben shapiro videos well
you are right you should but first like
and subscribe
perfect i'll see you in the next video